- All right.
It's 3:30.
Hello everybody, and welcome.
I am Andrew Doris, I'm a grad student here
at the Jackson Institute
for Global Affairs,
as well as the student
organizer of today's debate
on alternative voting methods
sponsored by Yale Effective Altruism.
Thank you all for coming.
You are all invited to
ask questions at any time
in the chat box at the
bottom of your screen.
And at the end, I will reappear to relay
as many of those questions
as possible to our panelists,
but for now it is my
privilege to introduce
our esteemed moderator,
Lisa D. T. Rice is an
independent political strategist
who passionate about democracy reform
and political innovation.
She is on the Board of
Directors for Unite America,
which is a non-partisan political movement
working to foster a representative
and functional government.
She's also on the Board of Directors
for the National Coalition
for Cancer Survivorship,
as an influential advocate
for multiple causes,
including cancer policy reform,
women's leadership and
empowerment, and political reform.
In last year's election cycle,
Lisa moderated a debate of six candidates
vying for the U.S house seat
for the District of Columbia.
So, today's debate should be
a piece of cake by comparison.
She holds a BA from Newcomb college,
and is the president of the
Newcomb Alumni Association,
and also holds an SM Degree in Management
from the MIT Sloan school.
Lisa, thank you so much
for being here today.
- You're welcome Andrew.
Hi, and good afternoon, everyone.
I'm really happy to be here today,
and we're going to talk about something
that is actually pretty exciting to me,
because I think that
if we can vote better,
we will have better turnout,
will attract more people to voting,
and the more people that
vote the better the results,
that's my personal opinion.
So, we won't talk about my
personal opinion anymore,
we'll get into introducing Lee and Aaron.
Lee Drutman is a Senior Fellow
in the political reform
program at New America.
He is the author of "Breaking
the Two-Party Doom Loop:
The Case for Multiparty
Democracy in America",
and "The Business of America is Lobbying".
He's winner of the 2016
American Political Science Association's
Robert A. Dahl Award,
given for scholarship
of the highest quality on
the subject of democracy.
Lee is also co-host of the
podcast Politics in Question,
and writes for the New York
times, Vox, and fivethirtyeight,
among other outlets.
He holds a PhD in Political Science
from the University of
California, Berkeley,
and a BA from Brown University.
Also we have Aaron Hamlin.
Aaron is the Executive
Director and Co-founder
of the Center for Election Science.
He's been featured as an
electoral assistance expert
on MS, NBC, NPR, Free Speech
TV, Inside Philanthropy
80,000 hours, Popular Mechanics,
and has given talks around
the country on voting methods.
He's written for Deadspin,
USA Today magazine,
Independent Voter Network, and others.
Additionally, Aaron is
a licensed attorney,
with two additional graduate
degrees in the social sciences.
Thank you both for being here today,
and we will kick it off with Lee,
and explain a little bit
about Rank Choice Voting,
and we've got a video,
and then we'll follow with Aaron,
who's got another video
about Approval Voting,
and I will ask Lee to kick it off.
- Great.
Well thank you for that introduction.
And I'm really thrilled
to be having this conversation today.
I think it's a really
important conversation,
because I think there's
a tremendous frustration
with our current voting system.
I think what we all
participating in this debate
agree that the Single
Winner plurality system
has some really perverse effects.
It limits choice,
it makes it hard for people to express
their sincere preferences,
and it's driving incredible
divisiveness in our politics.
So, I'm excited to have this conversation,
because I think there's a bunch
of Single Winner elections
in our political system
that are just inherently
gonna be Single Winner,
obviously president,
but also a governor's
races, senators races,
mayors races, and for
these Single Winner seats,
we ought to think about
what the better system is.
So, I think the best way to
explain voting systems is
with fun cartoon videos,
as we can all agree on.
So, let's run the fun cartoon video
for Rank Choice Voting if we can.
(dramatic music)
- [Cartoon Explainer] So,
what is Ranked Choice Voting?
In most parts of the United States,
voters select a single candidate
for each position on their ballot,
and the candidate with
the most votes wins.
This is known as a Single
Choice Winner Take All,
which can sometimes result in
the election of a candidate
who weren't only a small
percentage of the vote,
even when the majority of voters
supported other candidates.
But that's not the only way
of electing our leaders.
Ranked Choice Voting is
another voting method
which allows voters to
rank their candidates
in order of preference.
In a Ranked Choice Voting
election, a candidate needs
to earn more than half
of the votes to win.
All first choices are counted,
and if a candidate has a majority,
then they win just like
any other election.
If not, the candidate with the
fewest votes is eliminated,
and voters who that
candidate as a number one,
will have their votes count
for their next choice.
This process continues until
a candidate earns a majority
and is declared the winner.
Let's look at an example.
Here, you select Orange as
your first choice candidate,
Yellow as your second, Pink as your third,
and green as your final choice.
The first choices are counted.
Yellow earned 35%,
Orange 21%,
Pink earned 28%,
and green earned 16% of the vote.
Because nobody won more than 50%,
that candidate with the
fewest votes is eliminated,
and voters who picked him
as their first choice,
have their bouts count
for their second choice.
This continues until a candidate receives
more than half of the
votes, or 50% plus one.
So, what are some of the
benefits of Ranked Choice Voting?
Ranked Choice Voting
provides more choices,
allowing more than two
candidates to compete
without fear of splitting the vote
among like-minded individuals.
Sometimes voters feel pressured to vote
for the lesser of two evils.
Ranked Choice Voting allows people
to vote for their favorite candidate,
not just against the
candidates they dislike.
With Ranked Choice Voting, we
see more positive campaigns,
and less negative advertising.
Candidates are encouraged to to reach out
to as many voters as possible,
including those supporting
their opponents.
They can build a winning coalition
with like-minded candidates
to earn voters second and third choices.
It's time to fix our democracy
and make our elections
work better for everybody.
We can do that with Ranked Choice Voting.
visit www.fairvote.org to find
out how you can get involved.
- All right, well thank
you, Cartoon explainer.
So, I wanna just talk briefly
about why I like Rank Choice Voting
in addition to the reasons
that were mentioned
in that fun little video
and encourages more.
Positive campaigning,
more coalition building,
more compromise.
But one of the other things that I like
about Rank Choice Voting is
that we know that it works,
because it's been used
for over a hundred years
in Australia, for a
hundred years in Ireland,
many other countries
around the world use it.
We know that it works
because all those countries
have I've been successful
thriving democracies,
Australia has a century
of moderate politics.
We know that it's widely recommended
by election experts who have studied
all of these voting systems,
and it's particularly
recommended in divided
and pluralistic societies
in which coalition building
is a especially important.
And that's because we know,
again, from a hundred years
of experience that it
encourages compromise,
and coalition building in politics.
And I think most importantly,
this is gonna be I think,
a a point of contention
in this debate, is that I think it makes
the most realistic
assumptions about how voters,
campaigns, and parties will behave.
It assumes that there
is going to be a level
of strategic voting,
and what makes Rank
Choice Voting work well is
that it's really a hard system to game.
It encourages people to vote
their sincere preferences,
because there's no real
benefit in not doing so.
And I think that is incredibly important.
So, I think it aligns
the incentives properly.
It has again, and I think
this is really important,
we have lots and lots of
evidence that it works.
It's just doesn't have to
be a theoretical debate.
We can go to the record.
And I think, again, it makes realistic
and reasonable assumptions about
how people are gonna behave,
both voters and candidates,
in very high stakes elections.
So, with that, I will
turn it over to Aaron,
so you can hear about why
he likes Approval Voting.
- Cool.
Would you like me to begin?
So, thank you again.
And it's a pleasure being here.
So, when we're talking
about Approval Voting,
I think this explanation
is gonna be pretty simple.
Approval voting is simply
allowing you to select
as many candidates as you approve of,
as many as you effectively
are comfortable with
serving in office, and the candidate
with the most approvals or votes wins.
That's it.
It's not a complicated system.
But just to do service here,
we also have an explainer video.
So, feel free to run the explainer video.
- [Explainer] What is Approval Voting?
Simply put, it's a better
way to run an election.
Let's take a trip to Plantsville.
It's election time, and Mayor
Blueberry is campaigning hard
for a second term in office.
She won the last election
with 65% against her opponent
Mr. Squash, and she still
enjoys strong support.
Once again, Mr. Squash is quick
to challenge Ms. Blueberry,
but this time they're joined
by a third challenger, Mr. Peach,
who shared similar views
with mayor Blueberry.
Mr. Peach, sweet talks almost
half of Blueberry supporters
into switching their vote to him
while Mr. Squash holds the
same 35% he had last time.
The votes are counted, and what's this?
Mr. Squash wins.
Blueberry and Peach have
split the fruit vote.
How did this happen?
Peach's supporters also like Blueberry,
but couldn't say so on their ballots.
A simple solution is to change
the ballot from vote for one
to vote for one or more, allowing everyone
to state all the candidates they support.
This is called Approval Voting.
With Approval Voting,
the election would have
gone quite differently.
Peach's supporters, no longer fear that
a vote for Peach will help elect Squash.
Instead, they show their sincere support
for Peach and also Blueberry.
They wanna prevent Mr. Squash
from winning and they do.
An Approval Voting accurately
reflects Peach's support.
Mayor Blueberry wins the election,
democracy is restored.
Approval Voting is more
than just a smart idea
in Plantsville, it's a smart
idea anywhere you vote.
Approval Voting is used by
organizations across the globe,
and for good reason.
It's democratic because the candidate
with the most support wins.
It removes the spoiler effect.
Even losing candidates
get an accurate reflection of support,
and voting your favorite never hurts you.
Start the conversation on Approval Voting
and share this video.
Then join the Center
for Election Science at
electrology.org.
Better voting starts with you.
- Thank you.
And Approval Voting really
is the simple solution
that we need to upgrade our democracy.
And we don't need
establishment gatekeepers
to tell us what we can and can't do.
Our democracy and wellbeing
is just too important
to have to wait for permission.
Indeed, in Fargo and St. Louis,
the establishment there
was not very excited
about Approval voting and
that's because they knew
it was going to challenge their power.
And so, when we worked
with key stakeholders
within that community, we worked with them
to help bring them that power back.
And interestingly, the two places
where we've worked so
far, Fargo and St. Louis,
I think on the surface it appears like
these are really different places,
but they were looking at
really three core components
of a voting method.
And these are components that we're gonna
keep coming back to.
One is, you want a voting method
that is robust to vote splitting,
is able to show a clear
mandate when one is present,
and being able to like
to consistent candidate.
Second is, being able to have an idea
of how much support
candidates actually have.
You wanna make sure that voices are heard.
And if you're not able to show the support
of all the candidates,
ell, you're missing out
on all of these different voices.
And thirdly, you want a
voting method that is not
unnecessarily expensive
and not overly complicated.
With the votes putting
in mandate component,
you had candidates winning
with just a mere fraction
of the vote in both Fargo and St. Louis.
Since Approval Voting
has been implemented,
we've seen candidates be winning with,
or leading with well over a 50% support.
And it's not to say that that
will always happen again.
No voting method can guarantee a majority.
So, like when we see Rank Choice Voting
advocates talk about
always getting a majority,
that's really an artificial majority.
If you throw away all
the candidates but two,
of course you're gonna get a majority,
any voting method can do that.
And we're gonna talk again and again,
about being able to share with reflection,
support for candidates.
We're gonna talk about polling,
and how that's played out
in terms of Approval Voting,
showing the accurate reflection
of support for candidates.
And both St. Louis and Fargo,
they were told that
their only choice before
was Rank Choice Voting, and so,
they couldn't afford
a new voting machines.
And so, Approval Voting was
really their only way forward.
So, we needed an approach
that gives winners
the necessary support to be
able to make bold decisions,
we need an approach that
encourages new ideas to flourish,
and we needed an approach
that is practical.
So, overall, we need Approval Voting.
- Thanks Aaron.
So, for the next 25 to 30 minutes,
we're gonna go through some questions,
and each person will have
two to three minutes total;
two minutes to answer,
save a minute for rebuttal,
and we'll start with Lee.
Why is your method
preferable to the other?
- Great, thank you.
I think, I mean, the easiest way
to think about Rank Choice
Voting verse Approval Voting,
is to think about fact
that one voting system
has a hundred years of support.
We know, the evidence is out there,
Rank Choice Voting works,
whereas Approval Voting,
it's not a new voting system.
In fact, it's a voting system
that is older than Rank Choice Voting.
So, I think one question that,
and I'm curious for
Aaron answer to this is,
why is it that, although Approval Voting
has been around for a long time,
it's never really caught on?
And I mean, I think that the history shows
that there'd been various moments
in which some organizations
have been have used it,
and then they've discarded it
because it just leads to Bullet voting.
There've been some other
systems that are similar
to it that have been discarded.
And I just think, for elections,
it just doesn't make a lot of sense.
Whereas we know that Rank
Choice voting makes sense
because we know it works,
because it thinks about
how voters and candidates
actually campaign and vote.
Now, I do think that,
I don't wanna be inherently
dismissive of Approval Voting,
'cause I think that
there are cases in which
a system of Approval Voting makes sense,
and I think there are those
systems where decisions,
where the stakes are low.
For example, if you filled
out one of those doodle polls
where you're trying to figure out
when a good time to meet is,
well that's Approval Voting
and that's the value of Approval Voting.
And it works because
under those conditions,
most people don't have
really strong preferences.
They're equivocal, whether it's
we meet on Tuesday at four,
Wednesday at 11, and everybody's
trying to find a time
that they can all meet together.
So, everybody's sincere,
they're not strategic,
so pretty low stakes thing.
But if the stakes were a little higher,
like, say it wasn't just for one meeting
but a weekly staff meeting,
well, maybe I think
differently about voting.
Something about me is that I
like to work in the morning,
because that's my most productive time.
I'd rather have meetings in the afternoon,
I'm more productive earlier in the week.
I'd rather have meetings Friday,
so like I'd say like Friday at 3,
would be my best time for a meeting,
and that, it might not be a time
that's good for other people,
but like the question is,
how can we find the time
that's maybe most optimal
for all people, assuming
that we have preferences?
And I think that that's
the fundamental problem
of Approval Voting, is
that it assumes that
people are equivocal and
they don't see any difference
between a bunch of different candidates.
And the reality is that,
when it comes to high stakes selections,
which are elections for
mayor, Senator, governor,
you sort of keep Single Winner elections,
people have preferences.
There are campaigns.
So, I think, curious why folks
who support Approval Voting
think that the election
should follow the same logic
as finding a meeting time on doodle.
And what are all the people who
recommend Rank Choice Voting
and have recommended around the world,
and all the countries and cities
that have chosen Rank Choice Voting,
compared to just a very few
have chosen Approval Voting,
what are they all missing?
So I think those are
some important questions
that I hope we can get to here.
- Aaron, why is your method
preferable to the other?
- And do you want me
to include my rebuttal
in my response as well?
- Absolutely.
Go for it.
- So, I'll use the three minutes then.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
So, in terms of why Approval Voting
is better than my Rank Choice,
I think, we, again, get
back to those three issues
being able to elect a strong winner.
And again, like when we're
talking about a winner,
one thing to keep in mind is
that nine out of ten times
Approval Voting and Rank Choice Voting
are gonna select the same winner.
I think that's something
that's not really talked
about a lot.
And we've seen this play out
through polling that we've
done in presidential elections,
Democratic primary, and another elections.
What really comes to, is
where the focus is in terms of
where the methods diverge.
And so, we see one example
here of potential divergence.
We don't know how Approval
Voting necessarily
would have played out,
but we see an example
of where Rank Choice Voting has failed.
And I think the clear example there
that no one wants to talk
about is Burlington, Vermont.
And that's an example where the person
who was able to beat
everyone else head to head,
that candidate lost
because of votes splitting
within Rank Choice Voting.
There was a vote spitting
with first choice preferences,
and that candidate was
knocked out and lost.
And you also hear a lot of
claims that Rank Choice Voting
lets you always rank
your favorite as first.
Well, not the case in Burlington, Vermont.
Conservatives, they were
told the same thing,
they were told that they could
break their favorite first.
What happened?
As a consequence, they
caused a worst outcome.
They had the progressive candidate,
the polar opposite of what they
would want win as a result.
So, it was a worse result for them,
and it was a worst result
for the electorate.
And that's because,
that's even in the case
of voters voting honestly.
They're getting a worse outcome
when they're voting honestly.
And another key example
of being able to see
when a voting method is performing well,
it's when it's actually
able to capture the support
of what people want,
including with candidates who don't win.
We see time and again, Approval Voting
does an excellent job
capturing the support
of all the candidates,
including third parties and independence.
We saw this in the Democratic
primary, for instance.
The Yang is a great example here.
Under both Plurality voting
and Rank Choice Voting,
Yang got under 10%,
whereas under Approval
Voting, he got roughly 30%.
This is a case where a candidate
with new ideas that needs to be heard,
when people support him
and he's getting ignored.
Had we used Approval Voting,
he would have gotten the
support that he deserves.
And we did a control measure.
We asked people how they
honestly thought there,
and we saw that lineup.
So, it wasn't just a fluke
and we're just seeing,
time and again, of these
cans getting ignored.
This idea of momentum,
I think is one that
doesn't make much sense.
So, sure, Rank Choice voting
has been around a while
but like it's also been repealed.
It's been repealed in Burlington, Vermont,
Ann Arbor Michigan, Cary, North Carolina,
Aspen, Colorado,
Pierce County, Washington,
Sunnydale, California,
it's failed by over 16%
and a number of initiatives.
And Alaska, like it passed recently,
but it failed the first time,
Massachusetts, it failed by over a 10%.
And we can't just celebrate merely
because a voting method gets a result.
Any voting method can get a result,
what we want is a consistent result
that gives us good winners,
and a reflection of support
for all the candidates
and Approval Voting is what does that.
- Okay.
Thank you.
Our next question is about
resistance to strategic voting,
but what I wanted to do very quickly,
because everyone might not be
the voting geeks that we are,
I'll say what strategic voting is.
Strategic voting, it's sometimes referred
to as tactical voting.
It's when a voter cast
their ballot for a candidate
that is not their first choice,
in order to prevent
someone else from winning.
And so, we'll proceed into
the next question, which is,
which method is more resistant
to strategic voting and why?
- Lisa, do you wanna give Lee a chance
for his rebuttal as well?
- Okay, Lee.
- I just wanna be fair to Lee, that's all.
- I guess you want.
So, I think critics of Rank Choice voting
often bring up the case
of of Burlington, Vermont,
which was one election
which Ranked Choice Voting
did yield a weird result,
and no system is perfect.
I mean, I think we have to
be honest about that upfront,
that every system, under
certain conditions,
can yield a an unexpected result.
If there were a perfect voting system,
we'd all be using that voting system.
But you know that's a fundamental fallacy
of selecting on your dependent variable,
which is picking the one outcome
that supports your argument,
and cherry picking and
ignoring the many number
of elections that have been held
under Rank Choice Voting
that have worked just fine.
And again, Australia has
happily used the system
for a hundred years, Ireland
has heavily used the system
for a hundred years.
It's been used in many
elections in the U.S,
and in St. Paul, Minneapolis,
Oakland, San Francisco,
is now being used in
New York in the primary,
it's in Maine, it's in Alaska.
And yes, it's not gonna win
every ballot initiative,
because a lot of people
haven't heard of it,
and they don't understand it yet,
but the more people understand it,
the more people are
enthusiastic about that.
And I know that having
watched the progress
of Rank Choice Voting
over the last few years,
that once people get it, they like it.
- Okay.
Are we ready to move
into the next question?
Aaron, do you wanna
answer the next question?
Should I restate it?
- [Aaron] Sure, maybe for the audience.
- Which method is more resistant
to strategic voting and why?
- So, here, when we're talking
about strategic voting,
the idea of someone voting in a way
that benefits them overall,
I think perhaps more important here is
how does someone
optimizing their own vote,
voting the way that
they feel is necessary,
how does that play into the outcome?
Because if it doesn't give you,
if the voting method is
robust to strategic voting
and still gives you a strong outcome,
then I don't think
there's a big worry there.
So, with Approval Voting,
I think a lot of the times,
opponents look at this and say like, well,
people are just kind of
vote for one candidate
and that's gonna be it.
Well, I don't think that's a big deal.
In some cases, it's gonna make
sense for an individual voter
to vote for one candidate.
If that makes sense for them,
that makes sense for them.
You can still have, even if
say, three quarters of people
are choosing only one candidate,
and then some elections that
may make sense for most voters.
But even with that remainder,
that's enough to cover
the margin of victory
to change the winner, if
indeed a different winner
should be necessary.
It also makes it so that
the other candidates
are able to get their
reflection support heard.
So, overall, I'm not concerned with this.
As long as you are getting strong winners,
that's the main concern.
And as long as other candidates
are getting the accurate
reflection of support,
then I think the voting
method is doing its job.
I would be more concerned
again with the voting method
that when people are voting honestly,
that they get a worse outcome.
And again, like thinking in Burlington.
And we have to pick on
things like Burlington,
because again, nine out of ten times,
these voting methods are
gonna get the same result.
So, we have to kind of focus on that 10%,
and as Rank Choice Voting is
implemented in more places,
we're gonna see more Burlingtons,
but really we wanna
focus on a voting method
that gets a good outcome and does its job
on being able to capture
candidate support.
And those are areas where Approval Voting,
hands down, does better.
- I just wanna flag something here,
because I'm a little confused.
I'm hearing terms like "good outcome"
and I haven't heard those defined yet.
I'm hearing terms like "strong candidate",
So, I hope Aaron will define
those in his rebuttal here.
I mean, Aaron is telling us
that nine times out of ten,
Rank Choice Voting and Approval Voting
will get the same result.
And I don't know what that's based on,
because they haven't been
run in the same elections.
It might be based on hypothetical polling,
or modeling, but that's
not the real world.
The argument that I'm
hearing right now is that,
we're really focusing on the voter,
and the voters satisfaction,
and the voters are important,
but they're also part of a
broader political system.
And right now we have a
very broken and destructive
political system that is highly
polarized, highly binary,
highly divisive.
And so, I think we ought to think about
which political system is gonna
help solve those problems.
But this question is on the
sincere versus strategic voting.
And I'm actually not sure that, I mean,
this is all hypothetical,
because we don't know,
because we just don't
have a lot of experience
with Approval Voting, that
the results would be the same.
But I just wanna, because we
need hypothetical examples,
I just wanna take what I think might be
a realistic hypothetical
example, which is to say that,
Aaron, Lisa, and I are
all running for Senator,
and I'm on the left, and
Aaron's on the right,
and Lisa's in the middle, and
she's gotta be the moderate,
'cause she's the moderator,
don't all laugh at once.
And let's say this audience is
like the American electorate,
40% left, 20% center, 40% right,
and yeah, probably if everybody
were voting sincerely,
Lisa should be the winner.
But here's the problem,
is that I would know that.
So, I got to tell my
supporters don't vote for Lisa,
because I think I can
beat Aaron Head to head
if you all turn out and
nobody votes for Lisa,
because she would get her 20% plus my 40%,
then she's gonna beat me, and
Aaron strategy's the same.
So, he's gonna tell his supporters
not to vote for Lisa too,
because he knows this,
and then I know this.
So, I know that definitely
his supporters...
So, you can game this out.
And what we wind up is,
that we've devolved back
into standard plurality, zero sum voting.
And this is the experience
of Approval Voting,
is that often just devolves back into
a Bullet voting with
the same demonization.
And frankly, I think Lisa's pretty smart,
and she might realize what
was gonna happen to her,
and she's not gonna even
run under this scenario.
Now, RCV is gonna be different because
it's possible that Lisa will still get
the 20% first preference choices.
But now, she's a lot more important,
because Aaron and I both
are gonna really want
her second choices, and
we have no incentive
to demonize her, 'cause
we already have our 40%.
What we want is to move towards the middle
and get her supporters,
and build coalitions.
And this is why RCV is
superior in my mind,
is because it encourages
even candidates on the edges
to work towards building
a broader coalition.
In Approval Voting, the goal of candidates
is to tell all their supporters,
or dominant candidates,
tell their supporters to bullet vote.
In Rank Choice voting, I'm trying to build
a broader coalition.
So, I think when we think
about these systems,
we have to think of voting systems,
we have to think about
them as a broader part
of the political systems.
We have to think about how
campaigns are gonna operate,
we have to think how
candidates are gonna operate,
and we have to think how voters
are gonna be responsive to that.
And the dominant strategy
in Approval Voting
is just to bullet vote.
And if Aaron's fine with that,
then I don't know why we
even bothered to change
to Approval Voting, because then,
we might as well just
stick with Plurality voting
and save us the hassle.
- Aaron.
- Yeah.
So Lee asked, well, what
makes a good winner?
I think that's a fair question.
So, a good winter is one
that has the maximum support
of the electorate over
any other candidate.
And when we do polling,
we ask people as well,
we asked their honest opinion,
along with how they would vote
under different elections scenarios.
And Approval Voting, much
more than Rank Choice Voting,
it lines up with people's honest opinion.
We ask people that in St. Louis as well,
their Approval Voting support lined up
with their honest assessment.
So, and that was even...
And also people voted for 1.6 candidates
per ballot in St. Louis.
So even there, like we're
hardly seeing Bullet voting
being rampant, but if it was like,
maybe it makes sense for
those voters as well.
What's important is that
we get good winners,
and we can measure good winners
while we're doing this polling.
And so, that's what I would say.
So, if you're getting
good results, really,
that's really all that matters.
- Okay.
Are we ready to move on
to the next question?
And we're a little squeezed on our time.
So, I'm going to ask a question,
and ask that each of you watch your time
on answer and rebuttal.
The next question:
Which method produces
more moderate winners,
and is this always good?
Lee, do you wanna kick off?
- Sure.
Yeah.
And again, I keep coming back to this,
but I think this is an
incredibly important point,
that with Rank Choice Voting,
we don't have to rely
on hypothetical polls
that are divorced from
the rough and tumble
of actual campaigns.
We can actually look at the
record and we can look at
a hundred years of moderate
Australian politics,
we can look at a hundred years
of relatively moderate Irish politics,
and we we don't know,
from Approval Voting,
because there's just no history there.
We can do polls all we want,
but polls are actually...
Aaron was talking about a good way of...
we wanna know what candidate
support actually is.
Well, actually pulling is
a good way to know that.
We don't, so, we have a way to do that.
I just wanna talk about
the St. Louis election,
'cause that is the case
that we have most recently
of Approval Voting.
And I wanna know that that
was a two candidate election,
not a Single Winner candidate election.
So, actually one point, even though voters
were selecting two candidates,
they actually under voted at 1.6.
And actually, turn out
went down in St. Louis.
So, there was this 22%
turnout in this election.
It was actually down 11,000
votes from four years ago.
And so, I think with RCV,
you actually get more
people using those rankings.
And so, you're more likely to figure out
what the moderate winner is.
And I think again,
I'm finding it hard to understand
what Aaron really talks
about a good outcome
is who who has maximal
support among the electorate.
I think what he's trying to get at is
who would be the condersay winner,
which is the idea who would who would win
the most head to head match-ups,
which is a sort of gold standard
for how you measure electoral systems,
but it's also impossible to achieve,
unless everybody ranks every candidate,
which is just not gonna happen.
So, I'm just perplexed there I think.
I mean, there is a fundamental
problem, of course,
in getting moderate
winners, which is that,
there's tremendous
polarization in our society.
And if the electorate is divided,
it's gonna be really hard
to find a moderate winner.
And frankly, this is
the fundamental problem
with Single Winner election systems,
and I hope we'll debate, at a later point,
the value of multi winner
proportional electoral systems
which are really important
for generating more moderate winners.
But I think we have to
work from the reality
of where we are.
And so, the question is not
necessarily which is the system
that's gonna most elect the most moderate.
So, though I think Rank
Choice voting would do that,
but more importantly, wishes the system
that's going to incentivize
the most moderation,
given that we have an electorate
that is deeply polarized.
And again, for reasons
that I hope are clear,
I think that system is Rank Choice Voting,
because it encourages candidates to build
the broadest coalition to ensure that
they have majority support.
Whereas in Approval Voting,
there is a strategic decision
of voters in campaigns
to try to get their
supporters to bullet vote,
which again creates the same divisive
zero sum dissatisfaction
problems of Plurality voting.
- Thanks.
Aaron.
- Sure.
So, when I said that a good winner
is one that maximizes the
support from the electorate,
that's what I meant.
Condersay winter is
another way of doing it,
but we need to talk
about voter satisfaction.
And so, when I said that,
that's what I meant.
And when we're talking about
getting moderate winners,
really like we're talking about getting
the candidate who has the most support
from the electorate themselves.
And moderate is going to
vary from place to place.
So, really, when it comes down
to it, that's what we want.
We want a strong consensus winner
when we're talking about
who we want to win.
So, Lee mentioned that St.
Louis was a two-person election.
So, here we have Approval
Voting being used,
we can choose as many
candidates as you want,
and then it goes to a runoff in St. Louis.
But I thought there might be
some naysayers ahead of time.
So, unfortunately, when we
were doing our research design
in St. Louis, we also asked
them how they would vote
if there wasn't a runoff, would
they have voted differently?
And indeed some people would
have voted differently.
The votes per ballot would
have dropped slightly from 1.6
to about 1.5, but ultimately
we have the same winner,
same winner order, and
roughly the same support
among all the candidates as well.
And it's important to do these polls
alongside real elections,
because otherwise,
you run into a fantastical hypotheticals
that folks dream up.
And so when we look at
a particular election,
what we do is we ask people, okay, well,
here's an option using a
particular voting method.
How would you have voted if
this was the voting method?
And then we also asked them
what their honest assessment is
of these candidates.
And we ask them that in different ways.
We ask them by using a Likert type scale,
we asked them by ranking
their honest rankings,
and they ask them who
they honestly approve of.
And when we looked at that compared
to the Approval Voting
data through the election,
it worked out well.
Like those lined up.
And there are a number of
reasons why Rank Scale Voting
may struggle here.
One is that, it's not very
good data to begin with.
When you're looking at rankings,
you don't know where the threshold
is for where someone approves a candidate
and and where they don't.
So, you're fundamentally
not having information
to begin, with, and also the
method is so complicated,
that many cities truncate
the amount of information
that you can provide.
So, if you don't get the
information to begin with,
of course, you're gonna have
trouble getting a good result.
So, even when a voting method
like Rank Choice Voting
appears to be getting good results,
well like we don't always know.
Because like, there's
a lack of information.
And when you have more
candidates, which by the way,
cities on average, have
eight mayoral candidates,
good luck doing that with a
Rank Choice Voting election
when people get tired of breaking
through those candidates.
It's much easier to do
that with Approval Voting
even when you have a long candidate list.
And that's how you get
these better results.
- Okay.
Lee, did you have a
rebuttal or are we ready?
- I mean, I think we're arguing
angels on pin with this.
What counts as a better result.
I mean, Approval Voting assumes,
I mean, when we're talking
about voter preference
and measuring that, I think
Approval Voting assumes that
you either like a candidate
or you don't like a candidate.
But Rank Choice Voting data is,
I think actually quite more informative,
because you are much more likely,
people mostly use their ranking.
So, people are much more likely to vote
for multiple candidates
under ranked systems,
and you actually have an
incredible trove of data
to see who were first preferences,
who were second preferences,
who were third preferences,
and you can vote for more
candidates down the ballot
without harming your favorite,
if your favorite is a leading candidate.
And that actually, I think,
generates a better sense
of who voters prefer
and broad support.
But, again, I think the fundamental thing
that's happening in this debate,
that I'm finding a little frustrating is
it seems like Aaron is trying
to abstract voting system
outside of the politics,
and kind of talk about
a pure condersay winner.
And I think it is important
to think about the elections
as part of a political process.
So, it's part of how people campaign,
it's part of how people govern,
and it's part of how voters engage.
And Rank Choice Voting is a way for voters
to be very expressive, and a
way for candidates to reach out
to a lot of different candidates.
And you survey voters in cities
that have used Rank Choice
Voting, and 90, 91, 92%
of people say they were satisfied.
They say it was easy.
It's a myth that people find it hard.
There's few people who find it hard
the first time they do it,
but it's really not that hard to rank.
We rank all the time.
What are your 10 favorite movies?
What are your 10 favorite books?
What are your 10 favorite beers?
So, I'm just a little perplexed here.
- All right.
So, I'll tell you what we're gonna do.
We're gonna table the
discussion for the moment
on which system is better,
and let's go to the next topic.
Suppose you convinced the
audience that your method is best,
what are the biggest obstacles
to reforming the existing system,
how can they be overcome,
and what can our audience do to help?
Lee, do you wanna start?
And you'll get three minutes to respond.
- Yeah.
Well, yeah, I think we're
at a real inflection point
in our democracy in that,
we're having a very broad
democracy reform conversation.
And some of that is around
the immediate challenges
of voter suppression,
and Georgia just passed a
very restrictive voter ID law,
and the Democrats response
for the people at H.R.1.
And we're really thinking
about what it means
to have a fair democracy.
And I think this is a decade
long conversation, at least.
And so, I think it's
important to think about this
in a broader context, that this is not
just about Rank Choice
Voting or Approval Voting,
it's about what is gonna make
for a fair, representative,
just, equitable democracy,
particularly in this moment
in which we are transitioning as a society
to being a multi-ethnic democracy,
and really dealing with some of these
very nasty and ugly legacies
of earlier regressive
Jim Crow eras in our politics.
So, I wanna make sure that we
are having these conversations
as part of that bigger conversation,
and I think it's important in this moment
to have a broad conversation
about alternative voting
systems, which we are doing now.
And I think one of the challenges is that,
we have to understand
some of the ways in which
our voting system itself is contributing
to our political problems.
As you mentioned, I'm the author,
of the book "Breaking
the Two-Party Doom Loop:
"The Case for Multiparty
Democracy in America"
in which I argue that,
it is in fact, our two party system
that is fostering a
incredible divisiveness,
and that a multi-party system
I think would work much better
because it breaks the binary nature
of our political conflict,
which is exacerbating
so many of these us versus them problems,
and also is allowing a political minority
to have outsized power,
because it's well-placed in our system.
And here, I think we also
ought to be thinking about
proportional representation.
I mean, I think there are real...
We're having this debate
about Single Winner systems.
I think there are real limits
to Single Winner elections,
although there are certainly
certain electoral offices
that require Single Winners.
So, I think we all also
have to think about
the equity aspects of this, and this case,
I think particularly,
proportional Rank Choice Voting
is a very good system
for a diverse society.
And again, I go back to what
election experts talk about,
is that, if you have a
divided pluralistic society,
you want a proportional system,
and probably a Ranked
Choice Voting system too
in order to build cross
coalitional support.
So, I think it's important
to get engaged in these conversations.
I think the biggest obstacle
is a lack of imagination,
a sense that just because
we have the status quo,
that's just the only
possibility that there is.
And this is a moment in which I'm thrilled
that we're having these
debates, because I think
it's a real moment to
look at what's gone wrong
with our political system,
which is clearly declining,
and if you ask me, you
can look at Freedom House
or any international rating,
now everybody's looking
at the U.S and saying,
what's going wrong.
So, we have to expand our imagination.
I think that's the biggest obstacle.
- That's the biggest obstacle.
Okay.
Aron, how about you?
- I guess I would ask first
so we don't complete a Rank Choice Voting,
or instant runoff voting, and
single transferrable vote.
Those are very different systems.
So, here, we're talking
about Rank Choice Voting,
Single Winner, versus Approval Voting.
And when we're looking at this,
I think there are two obstacles really,
in terms of like, and these
are in terms of like arguments
that are push against Approval Voting.
And here we here issues about
momentum and expression,
but first like we need
to recognize that we have
more options than Rank Choice Voting.
This is not the only option.
Approval Voting is way easier,
and it's free to implement.
So, we need to be able to keep
this in mind as an option.
In terms of momentum.
Well, the RCV folks
collectively have gotten over
a hundred million dollars over
the last couple of decades.
You give any kind of intervention,
that kind of funding and timeline,
I'd hope that they'd make
some kind of progress.
But the question is, given
all that funding and timeline,
why aren't they further than they are?
You look at Approval
Voting, as an organization,
we've been around with
funding for three years.
And within those three years,
we've helped over 400,000
people get Approval Voting
to help give them a
voice in their democracy.
So, sure like RCB is
further along, but like,
look at the headstart that I got.
So, I wouldn't really call that momentum,
particularly when you're looking
at recent failures like Massachusetts,
where it lost by 10 points.
That doesn't look like momentum to me.
And as far as expressivity
which Lee had brought up earlier,
this is also an obstacle
that we see with people
looking at Ranked Choice
Voting versus Approval Voting.
But if you're filling out your ballot
and you're looking at the results,
and you don't see your voice
reflected in the results,
something is wrong.
You look at, and I see a lot
of third parties being told
that Rank Choice voting
is the solution for them,
it gives them their voice.
You look at Maine, in
Maine, which was able to
use Rank Choice Voting for
presidential elections,
neither third party got over 2%.
If Rank Choice Voting is
supposed to help third parties,
where is it happening?
You're looking at their opposites there,
they're not getting over 5%.
Whereas when we look at Approval Voting,
time and again, like we
looked at the 2016 election,
doing polling there Jill
Stein went from 1% to 9%.
Gary Johnson went from 3% to 21%.
You're not seeing any of those gains
with Rank Choice Voting.
So particularly, if you wanna
see your voice reflected
regardless of what you put on your ballot,
you need to use Approval Voting.
That's what's gonna give you your voice.
- Thank you.
It's time for each of you to
give your closing statements.
You each have three minutes.
- Do you wanna give a Lee his rebuttal?
- That question we just put on a table,
and each of you got your
three minutes for that one.
- [Aaron] All right.
- I'll rule my rebuttal
into the closing statement.
- All right, well, you're up.
- All right.
So, I didn't know that a
hundred million has been
spent supporting Rank
Choice Voting efforts.
That's new to me, but it suggest,
to me that the funders who are looking
at voting alternatives
are seeing something
in Rank Choice Voting.
I mean, these are folks
who are very careful
with their money, and
do, from my experience,
do run all the traps and try to figure out
what things are effective and whatnot.
And the fact that a
hundred million dollars
has already been committed
to Rank Choice Voting,
suggests that a lot of
people have independently
come to the idea that Rank Choice Voting
is a good system of voting.
And again it's not, like,
Approval Voting has been
around for a long time,
Rank Choice voting has been
So this seems to me something notable.
I mean Rank Choice Voting is
not gonna win every campaign,
neither is Approval Voting.
The women's suffrage movement
didn't win every campaign
when it started out either.
Do wanna address the idea,
of the question of which is simpler?
'Cause that was a question
that we were gonna
discuss before.
And I think that an argument
that I hear from Aaron is that
Approval Voting is easy and cheap to do.
So, when I hear that, it makes me think,
well, okay, if it's easy and cheap,
why hasn't anybody done it before?
In fact, people have.
There have been various
uses of Approval Voting,
and there are a number of organizations
that have adopted it,
and almost invariably
devolves into Bullet voting,
and they say, this doesn't really work.
And like all voting
systems have trade offs,
and there's complexities,
and in some ways,
if you want a super simple voting system,
you can use Plurality voting,
but the Approval Voting
hides its complexity,
because the complexity is all
in the strategic calculations
of whether or not people should approve
of multiple candidates.
Rank Choice Voting, yeah,
t's a little bit more complicated upfront,
but it's a very difficult system to game,
and it really encourages
people to sincerely vote.
Now, I hear Aaron saying, Oh, well,
we know that approval works
better because we've run polls.
A challenge for Approval Voting is that
all Approval Voting have are these polls,
because there's just not a
lot of real world examples.
And again, I just as somebody,
as a trained political scientist
with a PhD in political science,
author of several books,
somebody who really takes research
and empirical analysis seriously,
there are lots and lots of
studies of Rank Choice Voting
with real data both in the
U.S and around the world.
So, you can look at a stack of research
and you can make your own conclusions.
With Approval Voting, it's
largely mathematical theory,
abstracted from reality.
Now we have a few cities
that are getting using it
for two winner elections,
not Single Winner elections.
And it's all theoretical.
I think the theory relies
on a bunch of unrealistic assumptions
about how politics actually works.
I think the folks who put
a hundred million dollars
into Rank Choice Voting
would probably agree again,
these are folks who don't
spend their money Willy nilly.
So, I think, with Rank Choice Voting,
we don't have to guess.
We know it works, and we know
that people are happy with it,
and we know it encourages more
positive compromise oriented campaigning.
We can look around the world,
we can look in the U.S.
And to me, that's a very compelling case.
I've looked at the research,
I've looked at it deeply,
and so have others.
I mean, if you don't believe me,
Barack Obama supporter
Ranked Choice voting,
Elizabeth Warren supporter
of of Rank Choice Voting.
There are a lot of folks
in Congress who support it.
I have not heard any support
at that level for Approval Voting.
- Okay.
Aaron?
- So, Lee mentioned the funders,
and so, I would really
ask the funders to think
about where they're
putting their investments.
When you look at a campaign
like Massachusetts,
like, that has to hurt when
you are seeing a campaign
that drops $30 million
and loses by 10 points.
And I think the reason for that,
one big reason for that is,
people saw that this wasn't
a voting method for them.
This was a voting method
for the establishment.
What Rank Choice voting does,
is, if you like new voices,
well, sure, go ahead.
And if you wanna put them as first,
but those are just gonna
get transferred over
to other candidates and your
voice is not gonna get heard.
And you see this explicitly.
Like I mentioned, Maine,
Maine was Ranked Choice Voting
opportunity to show itself.
If Ranked Choice Voting allowed
you to express your voice
in a meaningful way, and
actually get it heard,
Maine would have shown that
But Rank Choice Voting
is ignoring your voice.
If Rank Choice voting would
have worked for new voices,
you would have seen more support
for third parties in Maine,
a state that's known
for independent voices.
So, when we're looking at this,
again we have to go back and think
what are the core components that we need
in a voting method?
We need a voting method
that gets us clear winners.
We have real data right now in St. Louis.
We had previously a mayor
who won with a fraction
of the vote and vote splitting
among the black community.
It was so apparent after
Proposition D passed
by over 60% that the former mayor
wasn't gonna get away with it anymore.
She decided not to run as an incumbent.
She decided not to run
because she saw the writing
on the wall that the people's
voice was gonna be heard,
and it was heard.
That the candidate that previously lost,
now was leading with well over 50%
in that first round,
going into the runoff.
So, we have real-world data.
And the reason that we do
polling alongside of this,
is to see whether the actual best winner
was the one who won.
We can't just at an election and say,
Oh, well, there, there was a result there,
a voting method succeeded.
You have to take data alongside that
to see whether the
winner was a good winner.
And you don't know that
unless you collect the data.
That's what we do.
Otherwise, you're just
hypothesizing or speculating
whether your voting method work.
You can't do that.
You actually have to collect data
to be able to tell whether your
voting method was effective.
And that's what we do.
And so, we have a solution
in front of us right now
that is easy to implement,
and it's easy to understand.
You have a drastically better alternative
than you've been told.
You don't have to wait for permission.
They're not gonna give
you permission anyway.
You have to demand it.
So I ask that you join us
in a room to spread Approval Voting.
Our democracy needs you now,.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
I think that Andrew
might have some questions
from the audience.
If not, I have a question of my own,
and then I have a question
that someone sent to me
earlier in the week
- Or so do I ever have questions?
There have been 112 questions submitted
in the chat below us.
- Holly guacamole!
- There is no way that I will be able
to get through all of them.
I have tried to identify a
handful that had common themes
throughout, but I'll let you go firstly.
So, you said you had
one on top of your head,
and we want to hear your thoughts as well.
- Yeah.
So, my question is for Andrew.
A couple of times you...
Not Andrew, I'm sorry.
Aaron, and Aaron, a couple
of times you've referred to
Maine showing that the
third party candidates,
that didn't really work for them.
So can you walk us through
why Maine was a failure
from your perspective?
- Yeah, so, in Maine, neither
the Green party candidate
nor the Libertarian party
candidate got more than 2%.
And so, we have to ask ourselves, like,
did they actually have
more support than 2%?
And surely they did.
And the reason that Rank
Choice Voting fails to show
that support is because it just ignores,
it thoroughly ignores data.
So, you look at all the
information that people put down
on their ballot.
So, if a candidate isn't
eliminated into a later round,
all the lower rankings for those ballots,
never even acknowledged
by the voting method.
And so, that never is reflected at all
in terms of support for
those third party candidates.
Whereas with Approval Voting,
doesn't ignore any data.
It uses all of the information.
So, if you have a voice
that you wanna give,
Approval Voting picks up on that,
cause it doesn't ignore anything.
And that works out
excellently for third parties,
independents, because their
voice is always heard.
- Okay.
Thank you.
Andrew, did you wanna
start with your questions
from the audience.
- So, we have about 10 minutes left
in what was scheduled.
I'm all right with going a
little bit over with that,
if you are, but not too far much further.
So, I have one question targeted
to each of you respectively,
and then a question for both
of you to answer at the end.
So Lee, I'll start with you.
Several audience members
have questioned just how well
Rank Choice Voting has
actually worked in Ireland
or Australia.
They've asked whether it's
particularly popular there,
or whether it has succeeded
in developing strong third parties.
One of them pointed out that
Australia has fewer independent
or minor party seats than say Canada,
even though Canada still
use first past the post.
So, do you have a response to that?
And then how important is the
attraction of third parties
as a criteria in evaluating these systems
compared to other things?
- Well, look, if you want third parties,
you have to get rid of
Single Winner elections.
I mean, it's just as simple as that.
Aaron accuses me of
conflating RCV with STV,
which is the multi winner
form of Rank Choice Voting.
I see it as a family of systems.
We're debating the Single Winner form
of Ranked Choice Voting, but
I think we have to consider
the whole family of Rank
Choice Voting system.
Ireland has three to five parties roughly,
Ireland does use the multi winner forms.
Australia use the Single
Winner form for its house,
which tends to have two
parties use the multi winner
for it's Senate, which
tends to have more parties.
Canada has a high degree of federalism,
which allows for multiple parties
in the strong Quebec block.
Look, if you had...
I mean, Aaron's talking
about the Green party
in presidential elections,
and in a year in which
the stakes were very high,
there was just not a lot of
attention on third party.
And I mean, maybe the
Green party would have
gotten 4% of 2%.
I mean, this is kind of
picking on the edges.
So, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Single one Ranked Choice
Voting is not gonna generate
a ton of support for third parties,
but neither is Approval Voting either.
You have to move past
the Single Winner format
if you really want multiple parties.
And I mean, I'm honestly confused
when Aaron's talking about
the establishment supporting
Rank Choice Voting
because, if he had followed the campaign
at all in Maine, he knew
that the establishment there
was incredibly against Rank Choice Voting,
and it took two initiatives
in order to get it passed,
because the established
firm tried to shut it down.
So, that part is confusing
to me, to confess.
- Aaron, my next question for you,
you can squeeze in a little
response to that if you want,
just 'cause I know we're trying to allow
equitable response times.
The Approval Voting specific
question that I had was,
is there any hazard regarding the variance
from person to person
in what approval means?
Or the different thresholds
that some people would express
that they approve of a
candidate in their positions,
whereas Rank Choice Voting
kind of gets around that,
because were only expressing
relative preferences
rather than an absolute one.
So, how much is that ambiguity
in what approval signifies
a problem to the accuracy
of approval voting results?
- That threshold per individual may vary.
But despite that, when we were looking at
honest assessments as the
electorate as a whole,
we're still seeing that
strong winner getting elected,
and ultimately that's what matters.
I'm a little put off by
these responses about
it not mattering about
being able to capture
third-parties or independent support.
These are new voices, and also we...
But this is basically arguing for is that
we ignore people's voice.
And I don't think that's just at all.
So, like when we look at
the Democratic primary
for instance, I pointed out
that Yang, for instance,
under both Rank Choice
voting and Plurality voting
was getting under 10%.
Are we saying that it's
okay for new voices
to get marginalized, because
that's what's happening
under Plurality voting,
and that's what's continuing to happen
under Rank Choice Voting.
Whereas the Approval Voting
gives those candidates support
so that they can't be marginalized
when they bring in new voices.
I don't think this kind
of unfair marginalization
is what we want in a voting method.
And again, that's why
we want Approval Voting,
because we wanna be able
to pick up on those voices.
- Come on.
That's a bad faith
argument and you know it.
- I mean, just look at the data.
- Are we gonna argue about new voices?
Come on.
You know it's a bad faith arguments.
- Look at the data.
I mean, and Maine, these other candidates
are getting a pittance of their support
- You calling Green Party a new voice?
I mean, look, I mean, if the
Green party had more support
we'd see it in polls.
We don't need voting
methods and Andrew Yang,
I mean, look, Andrew Yang
has not been marginalized.
He's running for mayor of New York city,
he has a huge Yang gang.
he wasn't gonna win the
democratic primary anyway,
but he got a ton of attention
and he really did elevate some new ideas.
- I have a hard time
understanding how these voices
would have been picked up in polls.
They use Plurality voting.
When you use a terrible
measurement instrument,
of course, it's not gonna be picked up.
- Aaron, run all the Approval
Voting polls you want,
I mean, I don't care.
I mean, that doesn't matter.
I mean, it's a good question,
but when people are
actually having to vote,
they have to vote strategically.
So like, no...
I mean I'm not trying to...
I want more voices.
I'm the guy whose argument
for multi-party democracy.
I mean, I think we're rushing up here,
we're rushing up against the limits
of the Single Winner system.
That if you really wanted more
voices, you should join me
in supporting proportional representation.
I mean, if that's what's
really important to you, Aaron,
and maybe it is,
proportional representation
is gonna bring in a lot more new voices.
So will you join me in that?
- I'm a supporter of
proportional representation,
and if that's what this debate was about,
I would have talked about it more,
but this debate is
about addressing offices
that are inherently a Single Winner.
And it's important
that, for those offices,
that we'd make sure that we
get strong people elected.
And then when people have voices
that are bringing new ideas
to the table, that we don't ignore them,
because that's what's happening
under Plurality voting,
that's what's happening
under Ranked Choice Voting.
And we don't have to look
at hypotheticals anymore.
You can't argue that people
are gonna constantly use
tactical strategies in a way
that nullifies the election,
when we have firsthand
knowledge of actual elections
when that's not coming to fruition.
And as Approval Voting gets implemented
in more and more places,
we're gonna see even more
and more examples of that.
And it's gonna be harder
to put out those bad faith arguments.
- All right, well, I'm looking forward
to seeing Approval Voting implemented
in a place with a Single Winner.
I mean, I find it interesting that,
although we cite St. Louis.
Actually St. Louis has a runoff.
So, it's sort of like,
I mean RCV is also called
instant runoff voting.
If Approval Voting works so well,
then why not just have it
elect the mayor directly?
Why do you need a runoff election?
- The reason in St. Louis
that we use a runoff is
because in some cases there are parameters
about how a state may
interpret what a majority is,
but I think it's important to recognize
the new voting method
can guarantee a majority
by merely throwing out candidates
until there are two or three
just is contriving a majority.
So, in those cases, we're
doing it just to satisfy
a state's interpretation of majority.
And fortunately approved
learning is so flexible
that it is able to work with a lot
of different circumstances,
including the one in St. Louis.
But I don't think anyone
would argue in good faith
that traditional runoff system is
not a Single Winner method,
whether you're using it
with Plurality voting,
or if you're using it
with Approval Voting.
- But then why not just have
it for the final result?
I mean, anyway, that's
an academic argument.
- I am glad that the discussion
has become almost as lively
as the comment section beneath us.
There is one more question
I think we have time for,
which is maybe a little bit less,
where you might not necessarily disagree.
There's a lot of comments coming in
pointing out that there are
many other voting methods,
besides those, even within
the Single Winner limitations,
besides those we've endorsed today,
which is kind of ironic given
that escaping this doom loop
of only two options to choose from
is one of the things
we're aiming to achieve.
Star voting for example,
or ranking in some way.
So, what I'll ask you to close is,
using your voting method
of choice, tell us what
either your next favorite
method or methods are.
So, Lee what's your second
favorite voting method,
What's your third choice?
And then Aaron, of what other
voting methods do you approve
as improvements over the status quo?
- Well, I mean, when it comes
to Single Winner elections,
I would say either either
Ranked Choice Voting
or a two round election, runoff election.
When it comes to portion
representation I think we,
in addition to STV, we
could consider openness PR,
we can consider a mixed member proportion,
the New Zealand, German system,
but I feel like there's this desire among
voting elections nerds,
and it's a fun thing to do
to come up with some new voting system.
But yeah, the reality
is that we've been...
this is not a new debate.
It's 150, 170 year old debate.
And a lot of these
voting methods have been
debated and tried, and
there's a reason why
Rank Choice voting is a
very widely used method.
And all of these other
families of voting methods
are not used as because Rank Choice Voting
works pretty well.
And that's as simple as that.
- In terms of other voting methods,
I would say Score voting is
probably a strong runner up
to Approval Voting.
With Approval Voting, you're
looking at really kind of
rare isolated cases where
like Approval Voting
would not get the same
winner as Score voting,
maybe fewer than one in a
hundred or something like that.
But with Approval Voting,
you're getting so much for so little
in terms of complexity
costs and actual costs,
that you're getting a real
bargain with the Approval voting,
and looking at and comparing
with the alternatives now,
that you're getting better performance
than some of these alternatives
that are being proposed,
and you're doing it while not having
the complexity associated with it,
and not having to have
the the extra expenses
associated with it either.
- All right.
Then on that note, it is 4:45,
which is the advertised
close of this event.
Thank you all for coming,
both participants and the attendees.
We will post the recording afterwards
on the Yale Effective
Altruism social media
among other places.
So, you will be able to
continue the conversation
amongst yourselves, and thank you
for what I think has been
a productive exchange.
- Thank you.
Thanks Andrew, thanks Lee, thanks Aaron.